welcome back the national Atomic Testing
Museum recently went through a Rebrand
and a lot of exciting new changes have
been made and here to tell us more about
the recent updates we have Rob McCoy
here with us thank you so much for being
here Rob well thank you Jillian great to
be here it's so great to talk with you
this is really a staple here in our
community tell us just overall a little
bit about the museum and what you can
experience when you come there so the
atomic Museum was basically founded
it'll be 18 years this coming February
to Showcase all the artifacts from both
above ground and underground nuclear
testing wow what we've done more
recently is we're broadening the
audience to involve Atomic the atomic
age and pop culture includes literature
film music and so it's kind of a
happening place right now yeah and a lot
to see and learn and experience you
brought some things with you today tell
us about some of these things on the
table well this is part of the atomic
age and you know after the first nuclear
test which was in New Mexico in 1945 all
of the the toys and the books and all of
the gadget sprung up and atomic man
which is closest to you right there is
actually a comic book and it's quite
rare there were only two issues and then
it ceased publication wow but he had
been exposed to nuclear power and he
became this Adam man strong guy I like
that that's really cool and I see some
cocktails back here well yes absolutely
I mean the cocktail age you think of the
40s the 50s and the 60s and so this book
captures the recipes from all of those
drinks and this one actually is
available in our bookstore how cool so
you can come and shop around when you're
done exploring it absolutely you said
change is your middle name you guys are
always keeping things fresh and exciting
and so when people come down now what's
something new that they can experience
well beginning this Thursday we'll have
a brand new uh exhibit called the bomb
without the boom and it talks about our
stockpile pile of nuclear weapons
nobody has ever known what happened to
all our new nuclear weapons and actually
there's a lot of scientific testing that
goes on to make sure our stockpilot
nuclear weapons God forbid they should
need to be used can be used effectively
and so we are the first place in the
United States that is going to be
telling this story and that that
actually happens this Thursday and this
is just the first of actually three new
exhibits we have one in February that's
coming that's called spy and it involves
all the spy equipment from the cold war
and we will have drum roll please an
Enigma machine wow and so we're really
looking forward to that and then next
September there when Adam and he's going
to fly away he's ready next September
we're actually going to launch the atom
experience wow and it will be immersive
and it is going to knock your shocks
socks off well a lot to see and
experience thank you so much to come
down there and check out all the new
stuff going on thank you so much for
being here all right it's a holiday
classic